you know it's weird because it's hard
because I I'm trying I don't want to run
or distance from it in any way or seem
disrespectful to it but at the same time
I'm like yeah I want to be an artist too
if I want to do my own thing or I want
to have some identity of my own
Lisa Marie Presley has died she was 54
years old
[Music]
the only thing I can raise me and myself
that doesn't go over well then I don't
know what to say at least I didn't
compromise the singer's death comes
after she suffered a cardiac arrest at
her Calabasas home and was put on life
support after being hospitalized
her mom Priscilla was by her side
through it all asking fans to keep her
in the family in their prayers Lisa
Marie's survived by Priscilla and her
three daughters actress Riley Keough and
14 year old twins Finley and Harper
Lockwood
the sad news comes after Lisa Marie
attended the 80th Golden Globe awards
with her mother where Austin Butler won
best actor Motion Picture drama for his
portrayal of her dad Elvis in the 2022
biopic
[Applause]
came to the right place it
was mind-blowing truly mind-blowing I
really didn't know what what to do with
myself after after I saw it yeah I had
to take like five days to process it
because it was so incredible and so spot
on
and so authentic
that yeah I I can't even describe
what it meant we just celebrated your
dad's birthday a couple days ago so what
does it mean to you to be here tonight
no in just a couple days after his
birthday celebrating him again in a way
that the masses are saying we see you
know I'm just so proud of it all
um
you know it's all flowing really nicely
together I'm gonna have the birthday
right now and you know I'm here to
support Austin and Faz and film and I'm
so excited over the years when speaking
with E.T she praised her dad's impact on
the music world he was a very special
person and everybody loved him he's
still alive in all of us and we're
carrying on on for him along with making
her own music later in life Lisa Marie's
created duets with some of her father's
hits
[Music]
now Lisa Marie will be remembered for
carrying on her dad's Legacy
[Music]
for the way you'd never
doubt me
but most
[Music]
to you
[Music]